hi everyone uh good evening my name is
priyana tarajan I am an astrophysicist
and the current director of Yale's
Frankie program in science and the
humanities
I am delighted to have you all to
welcome you to today's wonderful talk
titled white Gold Fever The Story of
deep sea treasure and an environmental
Tragedy by the esteemed journalist
Esther honig
uh before I start uh giving you a brief
bio of Esters I would like to
um recognize our benefactors Mr and Mrs
Richard and Barbara Frankie uh whose
support for interdisciplinary
scholarship at Yale has made this and
many other Ventures around Yale possible
um in particular I give out a warm shout
out to Barbara Frankie who is in the
audience today
and um as part of my required duties let
me also remind you that for those of us
who are assembled that we are recording
this event and that all participants
will therefore have to have their videos
muted for the duration of the talk uh Q
uh questions may be submitted at any
time to the Q a feature and we will have
um dedicated q a session after um
Esther's uh a talk so let me tell you a
little bit more about this fascinating
um author um Esther works both in print
and audio to create stories that are on
at the focus of the intersection of
Agriculture immigration and climate
change
um a perfect fit to the
interdisciplinary nature of the
activities at um at Frankie she's a
fluent Spanish speaker with a degree in
Spanish and Latin American studies and
she travels to Mexico and across the U.S
to carry out her reporting she's an
incredible Storyteller as you all see
very shortly her work has been published
by the nation snap judgment Latino USA
national public radio and much more her
piece for Mother Jones magazine about
the spread of covid-19 inside Midwestern
meat packing plants were cited by U.S
senators in a letter confronting
corporate Executives so she also not
only tells stories but stories that make
us understand accountability
accountability to each other
accountability to the Earth
accountability to climate change she's
the recipient of the UC Berkeley's 11th
hour food and farming fellowship and her
work has been recognized by the Edward R
Morrow Awards and the society for
professional journalists she has been
invited to present her work at tons of
conferences and universities she cut her
teeth as a reporter working for public
radio stations across the country where
she covered everything from all the
opioid epidemic to impacts of Trump's
immigration policies these days Esther
noted that she prefers to work on
in-depth narrative driven stories that
stress as far away as possible from the
grind of the immediate Daily News so
before I turn over to Esther for this
evening I let me just mention our
learning by doing project please
consider contributing simple science
experiments that you can do at home for
kids to our website little videos take a
look at our website to see how to do
that and I also want to advertise our
event as part of the understanding the
nature of inference colloquium series we
have our virtual talk by Professor Brian
Cantwell Smith which is on Wednesday
December 7th and a discussion session on
the 8th both at 3 pm anyway without
further Ado I would like to turn the
floor over to Esther honig thank you so
much Esther for coming we're absolutely
delighted and cannot wait to hear from
you
thank you so much that was such a lovely
introduction
um I'm so excited to be here today and
share this story with you
um this was took many months it was part
of a strong team of editors and
producers at snap judgment and
um without further Ado we're just going
to jump into it and I'm going to share
this the story that I love so much with
you all so I'm going to share my screen
all right
white Gold Fever story of deep sea
treasure and environmental tragedy
so our Story begins um this is Belen
Delgado and he's the protagonist of our
story he first learned to fish at the
age of 10 and he's been doing this all
his life and I'm just going to start off
by playing you the opening cut of tape
from my story
foreign
standing on an empty Beach covered in
fog belind Delgado points to an area on
the horizon where 15 years ago he found
something that would change his life and
the lives of everyone he knew who is
well the truth is
it was one of the best chapters of my
life
from my family
for my town
all right I hope that helped everyone
get a little transported into this story
that's why I love working with audio so
much
so this is tacopon we have right here on
the map
um and that's where our story takes
place 15 years ago this is a fishing
count of about 4 000 people located in
Sinaloa Mexico with the most southern
point of the state it is such a small
town there's not a single traffic light
there's no grocery store
um there's one or two paved roads in the
entire town so this is a fishing Town
even on the the entrance to the town
There's a big Archway and it says
takapon town of fishermen
um every day at the beach there are
fishermen arriving from there every
morning at the beach there are fishermen
arriving with their catch from the night
before they're fishing mackerel sea bass
stingray shark
um they even used to fish sea turtle
back when it was still legal
um and everything here the culture the
daily life the Traditions it all
circulates around fishing
um
so this again is a catch that was
brought in from the ocean
um fishermen spends the whole night
working out on the open ocean catching
fish to bring into the market
um this man right here is holding
mackerel or Sierra and this is the
preferred fish for making Ceviche
Sinaloa is known for its Ceviche but
this town
um it is seafood and Ceviche I mean it's
at every party for breakfast you eat
fried fish
um it is you know seafood and fish is
your breakfast lunch and dinner
um and it the even the food itself the
way that they prepare the ceviche is
unlike anything that I've seen in other
parts of the state
um like again just to show you that it's
just such a big part of this town you'll
be walking down the street and you'll
run into someone like this fisherman
who's repairing his net
um it's it's just everywhere that you
look
um this is a stat this is a uh Shrine
for St Andrew he's the patron saint of
fisherman and the shrine is right it's
overlooking the dock where fishermen
will leave at dusk to spend the night
out on the ocean so they can stop here
first
um and pray for protection
so our Story begins
um here in this town and it's 15 years
ago and they're going through a
particularly bad spell there's been
rampant overfishing in the area and
suddenly the populations of shrimp of
fish are starting to drop off
you know many of the fishermen are
struggling to make it a living keep food
on the table there are families who are
growing hungry who are going hungry and
no one really knows what's happened to
the fish they just know that they're
gone
they wouldn't bring back anything in
fact many would say what's going on and
it's like well
who knows there aren't any fish there's
nothing no I you know I
it's getting so bad the local businesses
are closing people are even trying to
sell their fishing boats but of course
no one wants to buy them
and so one evening Berlin is sitting out
in front of his house with this old
friend he's also a fisherman and they're
talking after a long day at work and
that's when Belen decides he's going to
share a bit of Gossip that he heard that
day
and it was from a guy who works on the
shrimping boats now these are bigger
boats and they have large Nets troweling
Nets that they drop into the ocean they
scrape along the ocean floor and they
bring up shrimp
and earlier that day this man had been
working on the shrimping boat they
dropped their Nets in like they always
do they pull them back up and when they
pull up the net they discovered
something caught in the webbing that was
beyond shocking
it's one of those species that let's put
it this way it's one of the most
expensive things you can catch
right this is the kailyacha uh Kyle
means scallop and acha translates to
Hatchet and it got it gets that name for
the shape of its shell which looks like
a hatchet so over here you have one that
is open
um you have the entrails and then right
here you have this coin of white meat
and that is that is the part that's
consumed that usually eaten raw and it
is considered a delicacy
um I also understand that it's native to
the Sea of Cortez and this is a product
that it's a delicacy it's sold to
high-end restaurants all along the coast
in Mexico it's also shipped out to
Mexico City where it's sold again and
and very upscale restaurants and as
Berlin reiterates this is one of the
most expensive things you can possibly
find in their oceans
so no one had ever caught this type of
Kyle in tacopon before and they're a
little bit shocked by this story
um that they're that Akio has appeared
in a shrimping net then the following
week when a shrimping boat catches
another Kyle they bring it to Berlin and
that's when he starts to get a big idea
Flynn who went to college for Fisheries
biology he knows that this isn't just a
coincidence typically Kyle were jammed
between rocks and so when you harvest
them you have to kind of cut them out
de-lodge them if you will from the the
crevasse where they've been they've been
living so the mere fact that they've
been swept up in this net tells villain
that there are so many of them tiled on
the ocean floor that they can be
easily collected or
Cut Loose by The Gentle tug of one of
these nets so he's starting to imagine
that there is a pile of coyote lurking
beneath the ocean water
and that's when
um
when he gets starts to make a plan
so here is tacopon from satellite
imagery here the snaking river is the
Estuary and that's what lent this town
to being a town of fishermen that's what
it is founded for is for because it was
such a great location for fishing and it
is in large part because of this Estuary
so right here off of the the mouth of
the Estuary you have Playa La tembora so
that is
um it's right around here that this
shrimping boat is going down and
catching these coyo in its net
and so Belinda sides that what they need
to do is they have to get a scuba diaper
because this is deeper than any of them
can go
um it's about 80 feet below the surface
no one has the equipment or the know-how
to do to dive that far
so he goes to the local a nearby City
Napa about 45 minutes away they don't
find anything they drive two hours away
to the larger city of masetlan and they
still they can't find the equipment they
can't find anyone who's able to do this
and then finally building calls up a
friend in Baja California we're diving
as more common fishermen make a living
this way by going down into the ocean
and and harvesting mollusks and things
like Kyle
and um it's a guy a diver on the phone
and
um he gets into agreed to to come down
we asked him how much will you charge us
to do this job and he said how about we
make a deal if there's Caillou I won't
charge you for the trip
but you'll give me a chance to fish some
of it if there's nothing you'll pay for
my trip there and back okay so he came
but Berlin also wanted to keep this a
secret
let's be discreet so that this doesn't
turn into complete chaos everything must
be done carefully
I said you know what if there are Kyle
don't tell anyone
okay so I have a bit of an agreement
going on
um the diver comes down they take him
out to an area more or less around here
they get his equipment on the boat they
go out he puts on his white fisherman
boots
um and he revs up his air compressor so
no one is diving here with an oxygen
tank because that's far too expensive
and I'm going to show you what that
looks like in just a minute
um using an air compressor is the
preferred means of diving and it's also
very dangerous so the diver puts on a
lead belt which helps them sink to the
bottom He Flops over the side of the
boat and he sinks to the bottom of of
the ocean and about an hour passes Flynn
his friend his brother-in-law they're
all on the boat just waiting to see what
he returns with
and when the diver came up the surprise
he had
100 pounds
I said to him what did it look like down
there
you all are sitting on a mine of gold he
says
wherever you step there's
oh dear God
so the man had stumbled upon a massive
colony of shellfish just off the
townshore and this is equivalent to
finding something like sunken treasure
researchers would later determined that
it covered the stress a stretch of ocean
floor about 35 miles long
and a mile wide
to look something like this
and the estimated value was somewhere
around two million dollars
so the next day
Belen gets in his truck and he drives
two hours away to Mazatlan to go to this
big
government building where the federal
fishing authorities are housed it's
called konabisca
and he gets a meeting with one of the
higher-ups and he tries to explain his
situation
to prove what he's found he has a cooler
full of his shellfish of the Kyle
because he needs he needs them to
believe him and he explains what he
wants
he wants there to be permits for all the
fishermen in his town so that Kyle can
be caught and sold legally
and he also knows that there needs to be
some sort of Regulation they need to
have a quota system because if there
isn't some sort of intervention
this is going to be immediately
overfished he is aware of just how
desperate the men in his town are
because remember they're coming off of
the last few years of very very bad
fishing level so this is this is
important that they'd be controlled
somehow
and he's basically begging this agent to
come in and help and the agent says yeah
you know we'll see what we can do Berlin
leaves feeling like okay I've done the
right thing I've gotten the ball rolling
meanwhile back in tacopon unfortunately
the scuba diver from Baja
um is out there catching Kyle because
that was the agreement that they had and
the people in dacopon can see him from
the shore it's so close and they see
this guy a scuba diver diving in coming
up a little bit while later and they get
curious it's um there's always a the
link says there's always a lot of Gossip
between the fishermen so someone
eventually gets in their boat and they
they Scuttle over to see
um what is going on and they see all of
these big bags of Kyle thatcha sitting
in the boat and it's like a bomb goes
off right this guy goes back to town he
tells everyone what he's just seen word
is out and Mayhem ensues
um to quote myself for my story uh
almost immediately everyone in the town
some of whom had never fished before in
their lives teachers politicians
ranchers bought boats and hired divers
and men who didn't know how to dive were
signing up for the job there was money
to be made and everyone wanted in
oh
sorry
nope I might be missing a piece of audio
that's okay
yes okay
so
there's this piece of audio that I
wanted to share and the Lin is I'll just
read it for you
there was a doctor a good friend of the
fisherman
he bought three boats he didn't even
need the money it made me so mad so
angry to see this type of person take
advantage and they could give a damn
right so this piece of audio really I
feel illustrates this question that
we're starting to confront which is who
does this belong to you know and Belen's
mind in the fisherman's mind you know
they've dedicated their whole lives to
this trade and now that there's this
opportunity to make a lot of money they
fully believe that this is rightfully
theirs of course this is a natural
resource there is no intervention from
authorities at this point no one is
saying who who can and cannot Harvest
Kyle and so people are being
opportunistic
um and is often the case the rich are
getting richer
now one positive aspect
um to the discovery of the Kyle of
everyone going out and fishing Kai was
that very suddenly there's a ton of
money in this town it is exploding
um with earnings people who are just
making ten dollars before a day are now
making a hundred to even a hundred and
fifty dollars you know that is the the
price that this shellfish is earning
them on the market
and a town where shops are closing now
they're living in this moment of glory
and things are being revived shops are
being reopened everyone is looking for
any excuse they can to party
let's just say there was a lot of money
people bought cars and as much beer as
they wanted they had big weddings and
parties if they saw you walking by they
just offer you a plate of Caillou de
aacha which is something that we never
ate and now we could eat all we wanted
we felt proud We felt really important
because during this time the economy of
the acapan I tell you grew by one
thousand percent
Berlin started fishing too now something
that I thought
um was really important while writing
this story is that had it been told from
the pers had it not been told from the
perspective of the fishermen like in any
sort of traditional article they might
have described the fishermen as the
villains and the Kyle as the prey
and what I wanted to do was show that
these are families
these are human beings and their parents
and
that and for that matter
there are like most of us interested in
improving improving their lot in life
um yes there were parties and there were
bad actors who were exploiting the
situation
but because of this money people are
able to do things they could have never
imagined like put their children through
college or buy a car that they could
later use to start a business or install
running water in their homes
and so I often think when we observe
these situations
um things like poaching or the you know
exploitation of natural resources and
we're standing at this position of
immense economic privilege and I say
that as someone who lives in the United
States and we have a tendency to
sympathize with the animals that are
being
that are being extracted or hunted and I
wanted to show that I believe these
communities of people also deserve our
empathy
um these are people many of whom are
living hand to mouth truly on in many
cases the the brink of survival and so
um yes we may see them as greedy
um but it is not entirely that black and
white there is Nuance here
okay
so
a few weeks go by since the Kyle had
been discovered and the news has spread
people are coming from across the state
to fish Kyle and then the News catches
on and reporters have come to town and
they love this story of like the
Cinderella town that was you know down
on their luck and now suddenly is
exploding with opportunity and money uh
the headlines are things like the
cocaine of the sea is what they're
calling it another one is of course
white Gold Fever which became the title
for this piece
um and I found this clip from Univision
and they did like a long segment on it
um this was not just local news this was
National when it first broke this was a
big deal and people were really excited
and interested in seeing what was
happening
um
so I just wanted to show this to you
because we can actually see the folks
diving
right oh
this is
entirely in Spanish so I'm just going to
narrate a little bit I just wanted to
show people a little bit of what we're
seeing just in terms of like the talent
itself these are guys getting ready to
go fishing for the day to go catch some
Kyle
um this of course is the fisherman that
the reporter is shadowing and he's
explaining you know they're all going to
drive up about or vote up about 25
minutes to where
where this giant Bank of Kyle has been
discovered
so I'm gonna fast forward a little bit
okay here we're gonna see
the diving
okay
so as I mentioned
we do not use this is not a oxygen tank
that tube right there is what's
connected to the air compressor that is
forcing oxygen through that tube that
then goes into the diver's map that is
an air compressor that's run on the
gasoline right this is pretty
rudimentary
um here we have our diver and he's
talking about some of the dangers that
are inherent diffusing this machine the
tube can get tied up sometimes it can
break if the machine breaks will the
diver's underwater they have to be
careful they can't come up too quickly
look at the fence very dangerous
you see that he's wearing jeans and
fishing boots
and I think this part is so cool because
the cameraman actually went down with
him or they brought a camera down there
so we couldn't see
now you'll see he's holding a rope in
his hand
and that is
so the fishermen who are waiting on top
in that boat you see it
um they're waiting to see if they feel a
tug
if you feel two tugs that means that the
diver is ready to come back up and
they'll pull that rope and they'll
deliver him back up if it's one tug
there's something that's gone wrong
something has happened on the ocean
floor and he needs help now
um and that is the extent of their
communication
so as you can imagine
incredibly risky very dangerous and this
is how all of this coyote is being
extracted not just in at this moment in
tiacapon but this is pretty widespread
across across all of Mexico
so it's been
okay it's been about four months since
the Kyle were found and now the amount
of boats that are out on the water has
more than tripled there are about 300
boats out there on a daily basis and
they're all harvesting around 100 to 200
pounds a day of pure Kyle meat so not
even counting the shells
and this entire time Berlin has been
fishing under a self-imposed quota he
thinks that he needs to send an example
for the other fishermen because this is
the responsible thing to do
he owns four fishing boats and he has
fishermen who go out and fish for him
and he's only going to send in two
and
um
this is his way of sort of demonstrating
that we can control ourselves we don't
have to fish this into
Extinction
So at around that time a local
University comes May perform a study of
the coyote population they hold a
meeting for all of the fishermen out on
the boardwalk and they tell them that
this Bank of kite was so large it can
last 10 years
other sources claim it could have lasted
as long as 30 years
but they have to fish it sustainably
that means limiting how much is
harvested so the population can
reproduce
and this is Belen you feel like he's he
feels like he's found his moment and he
stands up and he talks to everyone
gentlemen we have to take care of the
shellfish we have to ration how much we
catch what do we gain by fishing 200
pounds each if they are not going to
give us a good price let's only fish 100
pounds per boat so they pay us a higher
price and the guy you will last longer
so Berlin understands they cannot keep
extracting Kyle at the current rate and
in no time at all they're going to be
back to where they were before with
nothing left to fish he also knows that
they're flooding the market with Kyle
and that's driving the price down it's
now at about half of what it was when
they originally started out
and he wants everyone to abide by this
quota and he knows it can work because
in other communities in Mexico fishermen
preserve their popular fish populations
by fishing under these self-imposed
quotas he knows it can work
but the fishermen they don't seem to
believe him
perhaps they don't believe that the
coyote will ever run out maybe they
think
um maybe they're so happy that they
don't want to admit that this euphoric
chapter well a fishing will eventually
end
and I think in many ways it also speaks
as something that Berlin shared which is
the mentality of the fishermen and that
is that you have to fish today because
you don't know if you're going to be
able to fish tomorrow
so this sort of survival mentality
short-term thinking is really what he's
up against and trying to convince them
to change
change their
their approach
so after about six months the
authorities have finally managed to
issue licenses for the fishermen and
they've told them that they're on their
own to regulate themselves
it turns out that konopeska the agency
that Berlin went to at the beginning is
such a rigid large government agency
that in order to do things like issue to
to enforce quotas they have to perform
multiple studies
um they it's it's like there's so many
levels of bureaucratic red tape the
system just isn't designed to protect
this sort of one-off Discovery it's
designed to protect populations that we
already know exist right there's the
fishing licenses there are patrols by
um uh people who are essentially uh
where Wildlife uh I don't want to say
police officers but
um you know there are people agents who
are there to make sure that everyone is
following the rules there there is that
system in place but it's not able to be
nimble enough to come in last minute and
try and protect something before just as
it's been discovered before it's
completely wiped out
so as more Kyle is fished out of this
bank that we saw off the coast of
tiakupan the divers are having to
actually go deeper and deeper to
continue to extract Kyle
and as they go deeper and deeper they're
also spending far longer on the ocean
floor and they're getting the bends
there are also issues like I mentioned
with the equipment
um there are pipes or there are tubes
that explode
um and
what the result is that seven divers die
because there is not a hyperbaric
chamber in tiacapon right they just have
a tiny little clinic and the cloud the
closest hyperbaric chamber which is used
to treat the bends is two hours away
and in one instance Berlin one of his
divers gets sick and he calls an
ambulance and they agree to meet him
halfway so they he gets the diver in his
truck they race as fast as they can to
the halfway point of Miss queenappa and
when they get when he gets there the
ambulance is waiting and they hoist him
into the ambulance and he takes off and
he gets to Mazatlan in time where he's
able to get a hyperbilt into a
hyperbaric chamber and he his life is
saved but there's just so many people
who were not as fortunate
and you know I think I can imagine that
there are probably some folks in the
group perhaps professionally trained
divers thinking
um wow how stupid were people you know
what were they thinking doing this sort
of work and for me it really highlights
the level of desperation just how far
people were willing to go in order to
have a shot at a decent living right
they're they're putting everything on
the line they may not know how to dive
properly they may not have a clue that
there's a specific limit to how long
they should be down on the on the ocean
floor all they know is that this is
their chance to to earn money for
themselves and perhaps their their
families as well
so at this point
nothing can stop the onslaught people
are dying Belen has tried to entice the
fishermen to fish less by giving them
better prices for their catch nothing
works no one is willing to relent and
this is when it becomes a race to the
bottom because when you hold back on
your catch
but you know your neighbor is just going
to go out and fish that portion anyway
why would you comply
and eventually even Berlin gives up he
sends out all his boats and decides that
he'll reap as much benefit as he's able
to because down the line he knows that
just like everyone else
he's going to be completely screwed
you know China school enjoy this moment
while he can earn what he can before
it's gone because they're all going to
have to kind of suffer through
um
the actor the the reality afterwards of
being left without anything to fish
and so we're now finally arriving at the
end of the story of Kyle bayacha nearly
a year and a half nearly sorry less than
a year since they were discovered now
there are so many shelves and coyote
guts that the fishermen have been
carelessly tossing over their boats as
they harvest and clean the coyote that
that's polluted the water and it's
ruined this ecosystem that allowed the
coyote to thrive down there for decades
this causes a mass die off and the last
coyote to be extracted or fished out are
already dead
so we're at the end of our story today
takapon is nearly that the fishing in
takapon is nearly at an end oh we're
fishing and climate change has really
brought the industry to its knees and
the young people don't follow their
parents into this work anymore because
they know it's grueling and it can't
really provide a living
most people including belin's kids have
left the town for work in the city or
even in the United States
so if my small presentation has piqued
your interest I just want to point you
all towards the full story which you can
hear on snap judgment the episode's
called mother nature and I want to give
a brief shout out to the food and
environment reporting Network where I'm
a contributing writer and they fund
reporting that focuses on agriculture
and environment and without their
support this story would not have been
possible
and now I just want to Pivot a little
bit and talk a bit about what I do as an
agricultural journalist
so
I have spent the last few years telling
everyone that I am not a science
journalist
and yet I keep getting invited to speak
at science events
and I think this comes from a place of
my own insecurity
um mainly because my stories and if you
listen to them or read them are not
often chocked full of data analytics and
and graphs I'm horrible at math
and um I might not even directly quote a
scientist in the work that I do because
I think it's so important to keep the
workers or the producers
at this the center of my stories
um but I'm starting to notice the sort
of shift you know I've been cultivating
this beat for the last several years and
I often say that I report on the
intersection of Agriculture and
immigration
and we're talking about Farm Workers
like you see in this photo we're talking
about meat packing workers and fishermen
like Berlin
but now I'm starting to think that I
need to change that to say the
intersection of Agriculture and climate
change
now more than ever the impacts of
climate change are increasingly relevant
to my reporting because these are the
people who are living on the front lines
of this crisis
as the temperatures rise not only will
this will our food be impacted but more
importantly it will impact the people
who produce it
so in this photo here we have migrant
workers who are harvesting lettuce in
Yuma Arizona they cross the border every
day from Mexico to do this work and in
the fall in Yuma average temperatures
are around 102 degrees which is the
start of lettuce season
and on average a U.S farm worker enters
21 unsafe days during the growing season
and by mid-century that's set to
increase to 39 days and we are already
seeing harrowing news of Farm Workers
dying from a heat stroke in places you
might not expect like Washington and
Oregon so this is very rapidly becoming
one of the top concerns
and we see this too in places like
tacopon right how climate change has
impacting them warming Waters mean that
the schools of fish that these fishermen
rely on are seeking cooler Waters out in
the open ocean so you'll remember I
showed you those photos of folks coming
back in the morning from having spent
the the night out fishing
so this means that the fishermen must
not now travel further in order to catch
their fish and that costs them more in
gasoline to get there it also means that
their work is becoming increasingly
dangerous they're out there at night
because fish schools of fish tend to be
more active under moonlight
and
um yeah this is all just combined to
make their job more expensive more
dangerous more grueling
and even if we Zoom back to an even
larger a more take a more macro
perspective on this intersection of
climate change and agriculture I just
want to point out that the many people
who have gathered in migrant camps along
the U.S Mexico border folks who are
hoping to seek asylum in the United
States many of these people are former
Farmers they were driven from their
lands due to climate change due to under
um under production of their crops due
to unreliable rains and weather patterns
and they move to cities and in the
cities that were vulnerable to things
like extortion and gang violence and so
from there
sought Refuge North so this is it's all
very very interconnected I think a lot
of times when I tell people that I
report on agriculture I get a lot of
blank stares and I admit that
Tim even to me it sounds a bit boring
but when we start to see our world
through this perspective of food systems
and who produces our food I think it's
really fascinating
um and it can tell you so much about our
politics our own sense of empathy and
even our our understanding of science
and um in our current generation I think
this is going to become one of the most
important topics of our of our time our
Farm Workers and climate change food
system and climate change
um
I I'm gonna
just
leave my presentation real quick because
I want to make sure we have time for a
video
um I Berlin was not able to join us
uh here he doesn't have a very reliable
internet connection
um this is also the day that his sons
are coming back from the U.S after a
very long stint
um working on a farm in Washington
they've been there for nine months but I
did want to be able to include him in
this presentation somehow
um so uh the folks at the Frankie
program were very generous and helped me
to put subtitles to a quick interview
that I did with him via video and I've
asked him
what does he hope comes from this story
being published and out there and what
does he believe that the fishermen have
learned from the Kyle bayacha
the podcast
is
algo
pero
because
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
productive
is foreign
Generations
Tiempo
says
this is
the
but I just want to finish up with um
pointing out some of the a little bit of
the different style that I work in which
is narrative storytelling and how that
can overlap with science to make it more
powerful
so you listening to my story if you have
the opportunity you might notice there's
not a whole lot of science there
um in terms of numbers and terminology
and
um I worked with a really brilliant
editor her name is Nancy Lopez and she
really worked with me to kind of trim
all of that out because she like I
really believe in the power of a good
story
um
you know unlike a traditional news
article these stories have begetting
middles and ends they have a narrative
Arc they have a character we follow on
their Journey
um and maybe they can overcome the
challenges they face maybe they can slay
the dragon or maybe they can't maybe
they can't stop all of the fishermen
from extracting this natural resource
before it's completely wiped out but
um the ideas that we follow them on
their journey and we learn to empathize
with them
and I think it's such an important tool
especially when we're talking about
climate change we've been so good at
ignoring this crisis for so many
generations even with the science really
being right in front of our faces and I
think it's because it's a huge concept I
think it's overwhelming and I think
especially right now we find ourselves
in these news cycles that can be
incredibly exhausting right like we open
up the news in the morning and there's
so many stories that immediately deserve
our attention and and I'm talking about
the pandemic I'm talking about democracy
in this country
um a war raging in Europe there's so
much to pay attention to right now this
age of information and so we really have
to work at how we can go about getting
this information this this notion
they're getting people to to care to
engage
um when we are also overwhelmed right by
the amount of information so I really
look
at a good story as sort of this this
Trojan Horse if you will that we can
tell a story that is entertaining that
is engaging that helps someone empathize
with a person on the other side of the
world could in a completely different uh
socioeconomic status and be able to to
empathize with them to see what it's
like to walk in their shoes
um and to see what it the impacts of
things like climate change or in this
case overfishing really does to an
individual or to a community
um and so you know when we
I think we've we've learned to think
about these things separately for a very
long time right like as I mentioned I'm
hesitant to say that I'm a science
journalist or that my work is scientific
um in nature but when we start to think
about how science and good storytelling
can be paired together I think we have
the opportunity to do something
incredibly powerful and immensely
beautiful
um how can we tell these important
stories in a way that catches the
attention of audiences that might not be
able to might not want to listen
otherwise
um I was just recently reminded of this
this morning there was actually some
research from Yale that was published
talking about how folks who are
Republican have folks who identify as as
Republican have a higher rate of death
from the covid-19 disease and so
you have to think you know the science
is right there right we all have seen
the science around covid-19 and unless
there is sometimes there's there's there
has to be a good story to accompany that
right and some people there might be a
bad story that is telling people
um
the wrong thing so you know like it's
it's how do we Embrace this information
how do we tell it through a story that
can do good in this world who can get
people again to listen to get on board
to engage
um as opposed to gloss over and as
opposed to uh
take a story in a direction that um
it shouldn't
um
so I'm going to stop sharing
yeah thank you so much Esther for such a
fantastic
um
talk and um explaining to us the
multi-faceted and complex human
interactions and the sort of this
interleaving of uh nature and human
nature and the decisions that we make
and the complexity of that process
and uh you know um science doesn't have
to be just about data science
um science it really does is done in the
larger human context and so
um I um I don't know I consider your
story to be deeply intertwined with the
scientific concerns and scientific
questions so let me throw open the floor
for uh questions I don't see anything in
the Q a yet so please feel free to add
your questions in there
um thank you so much for this entirely
engrossing and uh very tragic story
um and foretelling it and bringing this
all to our attention and a wider
audience
um ever The Optimist what are the
prospects for the coyote coming back in
this area and uh what are but then's
thoughts about what he if he's around
what he might do next time or not do in
that situation yeah Berlin is a big
dreamer and he is I think after I talked
to his family about just asking some
questions about his character it turns
out that he is ever the champion of
sustainable fishing and it comes to
anything from shrimp to sea bass he is
there trying to mitigate issues and
ensure that everyone is respecting this
Wildlife that's I think something very
near and dear to his heart and so I mean
it's been 15 years right since that
Cairo Bank was nearly wiped out
um and it had probably sat undisturbed
for decades I don't know how long the
estimates I'm not sure what they look
like but who knows how long it will take
to grow back the fact is is that it
likely will or that it already has
started to grow back
um and it's sort of like poking the Bear
right like when do we make the decision
to get a diver out here to bring them
back down to see what it looks like down
there now
um Berlin is very eager to do this he I
think because I took an interest in this
story really wants to to explore it with
me he wants to get a diver to come down
he wants to see what's down there now
um even though there have not been any
changes necessarily to change what the
outcome would look like
um he believes that fishermen than the
town have learned they learned their
lesson they would never do that again
and perhaps
um talking to him I really got the sense
that a lot of people feel a lot of Shame
for what happened you know that they
um didn't act in time they didn't act
appropriately and I think more than
anything the death of those seven divers
really weighs on them and so there is an
eagerness to start it all again
um but there is also this belief that
perhaps they would be able to regulate
it themselves and Berlin is also very
much interested in the idea of making it
into some sort of a farming system
so that things could be generated in a
way that I guess oysters are
um to have always accessible tile
um in cages in the ocean something like
that that would make this more
long lasting
thank you we joined him in his dream you
can convey that to him
more regards from Yale uh so from the
audience thank you so much for this
amazing talk I have a couple questions
first how did you come across a story
and second what advice do you have for
aspiring journalists who want to do this
kind of work
so I think I can answer that in in one
one scoop so I um I have a relationship
with this town that dates back too when
I was in high school I was at a public
high school one that really valued
travel so instead of sports teams we did
things do like a language immersion
trips and we had an exchange set up with
the school at yakapon so I went down
there when I was first 16 I stayed with
a host family I returned again
um my senior year of high school and
then just thanks to social media you
know my host siblings were my age and we
continued to stay in touch I spent
plenty of time in Mexico studying
Spanish so they were you know we were
always able to communicate pretty
fluently
um and so that's how I stumbled upon
that story
um Kyle was actually that story I
actually heard for the first time when I
was in high school and it was something
that just seemed so Mystic and so
unbelievable that one day once I just
you know last year it occurred to me
that I could make a story out of that
but I had the resources that I now had
the skills and of course I had those
connections and I think for folks that
um aspire to do this sort of work I mean
obviously building that skill set is
important but the most important thing
is that innate sense of curiosity and
looking for those stories in your own
life right like what what paths have you
crossed in your life with what sorts of
people
um what unbelievable stories do you have
in your back pocket that you might tell
friends and family when you're all
sitting down at dinner or
um when you really want to you know
impress someone with a good story you
know what do you go back to so like what
what stories are already a part of your
life
um that could be made into something
like a story an audio documentary and I
think that a lot of us have more of
those stories than we that we realize
so it's uh Esther if I may
um use My Prerogative to ask you this
question so Sinaloa is a complicated
place right because isn't that the name
of one of the big drug cartels
um in Mexico yeah I'm curious about how
the larger culture of that place kind of
steeped with that how do you think that
impacted
um the thinking the um you know the way
in which
um they viewed commercialization
um and
yeah yeah
um I can speak to some of that you know
this was 15 years ago when the car were
extracted so
um the situation was different
um absolutely now Sinaloa is certainly
um a state that's considered very
infiltrated and controlled by the cartel
um and I would say that absolutely
extends to talk upon to an extent so you
have things um the sale of beer is
controlled by the cartel in that town at
eight o'clock the stores that sell beer
must close their doors and then the only
stores that are open that sell beer are
owned by the cartel so it's pervasive
um the folks part of this organic folks
who are part of this organized um
criminal organization are looking for
any way to generate money
um incomes right I mean yeah multiple
strands of money and exactly yes that
you know sort of Ethics are not really
part of that discussion there and right
so it's it's what's difficult I think is
that you're looking at a town which
subsisted for so long off of fishing and
now that source of revenue for these
families is drying up and it's becoming
harder so your kids either leave to go
somewhere else or you're unfortunately
um they're you know you face the
possibility of working to some extent
with these organized gangs so I've heard
things like people using their boats to
transport drugs you know really
dangerous very dangerous stuff
um even things like uh cartel may be
funding the money for gasoline and
taking a cut of the the profits that you
earn from fishing and so this highlights
something that's really important which
is that not only is this area already
very unstable politically in terms of
who controls this state it's very
apparent that it is the cartels and not
necessarily the the government of Mexico
um but as things become more unstable
because of climate change people don't
have a lot of other options for making a
living
um you'll start to see an increase in in
instability yeah and I think um you made
the point wonderfully that you know
Finding sustainable options
um is really really challenging right
um yeah yeah and and Berlin is a huge
champion of there being more shrimp
Farms there being packaging houses
things that allow them to export to sell
to markets directly all of this stuff is
infrastructure that if the fisherman had
would allow them to possibly sustain
their way of life to some degree uh
there just isn't The Upfront investment
right and also you know be speak sort of
more economically self-sufficient in a
way and be more in control of their
Destiny right I mean I think that's
their dream that's what he's dreaming
right that's what they had you know they
had that and then it was taken away a
lot of that overfishing comes from
commercial fishing fleets from foreign
countries and of course we know that
low-income countries uh have not
contributed to climate change to the
extent that say America has yeah I was
just going to bring that point up that I
think your story is very emblematic of
the point that you know the regions that
are going to actually feel the impact of
climate change either directly because
of floods and other natural disasters or
a shrinking of their old ways of
livelihood are sadly not the places that
have contributed uh in a major way to
the um you know the carbon and to
um to to climate change and the
deleterious effects of climate change
yeah so I really found that your story
was really beautiful at sort of multiple
levels so thank you once again for this
this gorgeous
um study and book uh so we have a
question from um Sylvia back in the
audience
um oh sorry I missed one question prior
to that
um the question is from uh one of uh
someone in the audience who asked I know
you worked in radio journalism for a
while earlier in your career how did you
pivot to becoming a freelancer and
writing about agriculture
um I actually began writing about
agriculture I was it was my beat um it
was my last job at a public radio
station for NPR I was part of a regional
collaborative that contributed stories
across the country to NPR about
agriculture
and um I just found that I really loved
it and I really wanted to focus on labor
and agriculture specifically that had
been a passion of mine for a long time
and
um what I found was that I just got a
little tired of the uh NPR format as
much as I loved working for them I
really wanted to be able to do more
long-form in-depth stuff things that
really allow characters to evolve and um
allow for a bit more flexibility and
creativity and so I made the decision to
go freelance um in 2019 just a few
months before the pandemic I quit my job
and I moved to Mexico
and uh it had been a long held dream of
mine right to do International work
especially and so uh when it seemed that
the world was literally just caving in
on me because I had made this risk
during such um really just bad timing it
wound up actually being uh fairly
advantageous because
um suddenly the topic that I had now
spent three years cultivating this beat
uh was suddenly on headlines nationally
right um it became an immensely
important issue because we were a
concept for the first time a lot of
Americans were being forced to
contemplate where their food comes from
and if those people are sick they can't
process it they can't Harvest it and so
um in a way it was and I hate to say
this but it was
it was fortunate
um that the timing was such and so I
think those sorts of elements have
allowed me to to pick up a fairly
successful freelance career from the
beginning
thanks Esther so an insightful comment
from Sylvia um and we can build on it
and turn into a question she said she
wanted to tell you that she thinks she
presented the story beautifully I have
to agree and she noticed that you
avoided making villains which in a
Cinderella wind calls story might be
tempting the benefit of your narrative
left us eager to learn more and to feel
included so maybe you could speak a bit
to that
um how did you avoid that that glaring
temptation to identify
villains and protagonists
um
you know I think uh honestly it was just
trying to follow the good story right
the good story is the hero and then he's
at the center of it and we're watching
him step by step I think if there's a
villain in this story it's perhaps the
regulatory bodies of Mexico
um and as soon as that leaves my mouth
I'm like immediately kind of
it gets really boring right
um and we all know you know we all know
what that's like for the most part that
the the regulations aren't working
um I feel like we can assume that is
true not just perhaps in Mexico but
other countries around the world and so
there I didn't really want to spend too
much time diving into that
um just because I felt like it took away
from the story uh
and I didn't want to you know um also
make this about the other fishermen who
are coming in um there was a big issue
towards the end what Berlin called
pirate fishermen that were coming in at
night and they were fishing the coyote
before any of the other fishermen could
get out there
um these were guys from you know far
away
and um
I also didn't feel like it was fair to
villainize them you know like just the
the fishermen of tacopon were very
um
they're a very adamant that they weren't
going to stop people from coming into
their town and fishing Kyle because
everyone is just trying to get by you
know they're all in the struggles
together in a lot of ways and so
um if they weren't you know Berlin can
be angry at the doctors and the ranchers
and the politicians who got votes and
went in and fished with Kyle but
um I also feel that as a reporter from
the United States I honestly don't know
if their economic standing is even much
better perhaps than my own if they're
middle class in Mexico but you know you
know what I'm saying like I'm I don't
think it's fair as someone from my
someone from my position to necessarily
villainize anyone in this in this
situation because I've been born with so
much opportunity and and relative wealth
so I think it was just checking my
privilege honestly
no but I said it's also uh wonderful to
hear
um the humility the place of humility
and learning that you have come from I
think that makes
um the story I mean it shines through in
the story
so I think as you can see we are all
gushery fans
so um are there any uh further questions
for Esther
um before we close Ty did you want to
have the final question
where's your next story out of Mexico
what are you working on
my my next
um dream story is about these canals in
Mexico City that
um it's an area now called zochimilco
and these canals were what originally
the meshika or the indigenous community
that um Cortez discovered when he
discovered Mexico we're living then in
Mexico City this is the area where they
lived and they had built these canals
and their whole city was a floating city
um of course that's all been destroyed
and so what's left is a small region of
the city called zochimilco where some of
these canals still exist
um and there is this wild story
from the 70s when politicians in Mexico
wanted to make sochimedico more
attractive as a tourist destination and
someone had the idea to introduce
manatees into the canals and
um what resulted was that the amenities
did not survive it was not the right
environment for them it was far too cold
but then rumors started to spread that
locals were catching them and eating
them and making
um Manatee tacos and so I know this
sounds all really wild and Preposterous
but um it was a story that was so
unfathomable that when I heard it I
thought it was just folklore and
actually by doing research discovered
that it did in fact happen though it is
very
um it's a very sort of like distinct
chapter in Mexico's history and there
isn't a whole lot written about it
um but it's an example and a really
enthralling story I think about what
happens when humans
try to mess with a natural environment
too much right like you have a perfect
ecosystem which is this these this
swampness Canal area and you can't just
introduce whatever animal that you want
into it to make it into some sort of a
lucrative opportunity
so it's um we'll see we're still I'm
still working on it there's also plenty
of other stories in the works but um I
feel like that was more up the
sort of in line with the the Kyle vyacha
piece so we'll we'll see how it turns
out and when I can get back to Mexico
City to do those interviews I think we'd
all agree there couldn't be anybody
better to tell that story
well thank you thank you all so much for
for having me as a part of this um it
really was a great opportunity yeah um
thank you it was a real privilege for us
to hear from you uh thank you so much
Esther and here's wishing you the best
in your next adventure and we eagerly
look forward to hearing more about it so
of the Frankie program and the audience
thanks so much for coming today all
right thank you thank you so much it was
a pleasure yeah bye bye everyone bye
foreign
[Music]